I have some really great video today of
one of the most prominent bad-faith
actors that have surfaced as
brown-nosing Donald Trump sycophants
during the last two years and I'm
talking of course about Republican
Senator Lindsey Graham the trump
presidency has been sort of great for
Lindsey Graham and also a complete and
total embarrassment for him so on the
one hand Trump has been great for
Lindsey Graham because Lindsey Graham
sucking up to Trump has gotten him tons
of airtime he's way more known today
than he was before the Trump presidency
and in a sense his sort of personal
profile has risen drastically under
Donald Trump on the other hand though
Lindsey Graham has been caught in
hilarious contradiction after
contradiction and if you're paying
attention you realize that Graham is a
completely farcical political tool with
no concern whatsoever for the truth or
for what's right and I told you back in
April you might remember that even
though Lindsey Graham now says Trump
can't be impeached for any cover-up
actions like for example obstruction
because there was no underlying crime
for example conspiracy to collude with
Russia or whatever we found video of
Lindsey Graham despite that from the
Clinton era where he was actually
ranting on the Senate floor about how
Bill Clinton can be impeached even
though there was no underlying crime so
more recently I've told you that the
Trump administration is ignoring endless
subpoenas for documents and directing
witnesses to ignore subpoenas and
Lindsey Graham thinks that that's fine
as long as it's the Trump administration
but it turns out there's a Lindsey just
like there's a Trump tweet for anything
it seems that there's a Lindsey Graham
video for anything it turns out that
back in the late 1990s Graham also said
that ignoring congressional subpoenas or
directing others to do so is an
impeachable offense for a President of
the United States of course when the
president at the time happened to be
Democratic President Bill Clinton so Fox
News's Chris Wallace tried to call out
Lindsey Graham and it's pretty
interesting he plays the video for
Graham Graham doesn't really know which
way is up or what what's going on and
what he comes up with is just saying
well the difference is
Republicans act in good faith and
Democrats act in bad faith said that's
basically what it comes down to and this
all has to do if you haven't been
following it and I really didn't while I
was on break but I've caught myself up
on it this all has to do with Democrats
trying to get more information about the
Moller report redacted versions
unredacted versions bar etc and that
sets up the following exchange on fox
news you call all of what's going on
here in Washington a political circus
but you took it a different view back
when you were leading the impeachment
effort against Bill Clinton back in the
late 90s at that time you said that any
president and you talked specifically
about Clinton and Richard Nixon who
defied Congress when it came to
subpoenas was in danger of impeachment
here you are back then you're becoming
the judge and jury it is not your job to
tell us what we need it is your job to
comply all the things we need to provide
oversight over you question why is it an
impeachable offense for Clinton or Nixon
back then to ignore congressional
subpoenas but it's okay for President
Trump to do now
well there's two things here the Moller
investigation was a special counsel
appointed to find out if the president
committed a crime if he colluded with
the russians if he obstructed justice
the president gave him 1.4 million
documents to muller everybody around the
president was allowed to testify he
never claimed the executive privilege he
complied no cover-up work with Muller
mowers the final word on this for me so
if Clinton had stiff Ken Starr that's
different what Nadler is doing is trying
to destroy the president and his family
if I were the president I'd fight back
against this political revenge coming
out of the house Muller was the man of
the law Muller was an independent voice
that we all trusted to be fair I don't
trust House Democrats to be fair they're
trying to redo the Muller report they're
trying to make up other stuff and at the
end of the day it will be political
suicide for them to impeach if I were
the president I would fight Nadler tooth
and nail I'm glad it cooperated with
Muller that's the difference
so Lindsey Graham's explanation is when
he was calling people out in the 90s the
Republican Party was a responsible
respectable good faith actor and most
importantly they could be trusted not to
act in a politically biased way they
were just doing the right thing but 20
19 Democrats can't be trusted right
they are the political ones but
Republicans impeaching Clinton in the
1990s weren't being political I'm having
a hard time imagining a more outrageous
explanation like if you said come up
with a more ridiculous way to explain
the contradiction I don't know that I
could do better than the absurdity of
what Lindsey Graham actually said but I
want to try to zoom out a little bit and
take like a bigger picture view here
rather than focusing on the specifics of
Lindsey Graham's blatant and obvious
political posturing
none of these elected officials have
your best interests in mind
meaning Democrats play political games
and Republicans play political games
Democrats play politics with subpoenas
and congressional testimony and
Republicans do the exact same thing
there were rampant politics around the
Bill Clinton impeachment and the Ken
Starr investigation no matter what
Lindsey Graham says and yes there are
rampant politics today from Democrats
around the Trump stuff but don't mistake
what I'm saying for me playing this both
sides do it equally sort of thing I'm
not doing the phone neutrality BS that
you might hear on some other shows the
pathetic fence sitting milquetoast
everybody is doing the same stuff on
both sides thing that adds nothing the
conversation that's not what I mean
both sides play politics with all of
this but when Republicans were doing it
with Bill Clinton it was about a lie
related to oral sex okay Democrats are
now using the same I admit these are
tired tactics these are depressing
political techniques but Democrats are
doing it to try to figure out the full
scope of what criminality may have been
undertaken by the President of the
United States and people around him to
figure out the full scope of the
kleptocratic disaster that is this
administration that has been
participating in a
deliberate self-enrichment and and and
violations or moves away from the
systems of checks and balances that we
have so yeah both sides do this garbage
congressional subpoenas are political
tools a lot of these things are
political tools that we've been seeing
for decades on this uh in this country
but you have to understand the
pernicious role that bottom feeders like
Lindsey Graham have in 2019 versus
thinking back to the 90s and what Bill
Clinton's impeachment was all about do
not fall for this truly moronic
explanation for Lindsey Graham now
unfortunately Chris Wallace didn't
really follow up about the absurdity of
it but at least we got the clip that we
got let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show if you love
learning new things you probably want to
check this out the david pakman show
today is sponsored by Skillshare and
we're giving you two entire months of
free access to Skillshare when you click
the link underneath this video
Skillshare is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video